bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors il
semblerait que le président macron
choisissent enfin si j'ose dire une
approche locale
mieux vaut tard que jamais
oui clairement après avoir ignoré les
élus locaux les élus des territoires
pendant des mois et même macron décide
finalement de tendre un peu l'oreille et
d'envoyer ses ministres olivier ferrand
est allé à nice ce week end jean castex
a pris le temps d'appeler l'élu de
dunkerque eux pour voir ce qu'il se
passait un peu en région et être au plus
près du territoire
l'idée c'est de changer de braquet c'est
vrai que cela était ignorée par la
stratégie de l'exécutif
tout se passe finalement derrière des
portes closes avec ce conseil sanitaire
ce conseil des ministres et puis
finalement plus rien et là on se rend
compte que l'exécutif va utiliser les
préfets en local veut rester maître du
tempo quand même parce que comme le
disait votre invité les élus locaux
notamment les élus du grand dunkerque
réclamait depuis plus d'une dizaine de
jours des mesures plus fortes notamment
la fermeture des écoles l'allongement
des vacances scolaires pour limiter
l'incidence bien sûr la propagation du
virus puisque il ya dix jours le taux
d'incidence c'était seulement 2 485 pour
cent mille personnes quelque 185 cas et
voilà que nous sommes maintenant à 900
quasiment 1000 cas si la réaction avait
été plus rapide à l'elysée alors
peut-être qu'on aurait pu circonscrire
le problème
il essaie de se donner la belle image
d'être dans l'action alors qu'en réalité
on est toujours un temps de retard au
niveau du gouvernement
alors l ex éviter le confinement agir au
plus près des besoins en urgence est
donc clairement l'acte de la fameuse
nouvelle stratégie on est loin des
britanniques
on en parlait quelques instants qui eux
ont tout planifié jusqu'à fin juin
oui c'est clair boris johnson a donné
des dates d'ailleurs en fonction des
commerces en fonction de la campagne de
vaccination
en fait en france tout se passe pour
faire oublier la pénurie de vaccins pour
faire comme si tout allait bien et comme
ci-dessous suivait une courbe un
planifié par
main de maître par les cabinets de
consulting mckinsey en tête et tous les
autres qui ont récupéré des milliers des
millions d'euros auprès du gouvernement
pour les conseiller dans ses stratégies
ma foi délétère de gestion de la crise
sanitaire et donc on est en train de
transformer un échec en victoire et
surtout emmanuel macron qui a repris les
commandes en disant je fais des choix
politiques
je mets les médecins loin des décisions
parce que maintenant il est question de
l'économie parce que on n'en parle pas
assez
quand même en 2020 c'est un français sur
six qui est passé sous le seuil de
pauvreté avec le déficit de la balance
du commerce extérieur qui ne fait
qu'empirer
sans parler bien sûr de la dette covit
donc tout se passe pour dire que tout va
pour le mieux mais il s'agit de la
communication d'ailleurs ça se voit
emmanuel macron président de la
république fait appel à des influenceurs
sur youtube mc fly et carlito leur
demandant de faire une chanson pour
rappeler les gestes barrière
gabriella talent porte parole du
gouvernement qui demain mercredi va
étrenner son studio tout neufs depuis
l'elysée pour devenir lui-même à youtube
heures avec des jeunes pour répondre aux
questions des jeunes on en est là tout
est campagne de communication tout est
finalement start up nation mais rien est
dans l'action rien n'est dans la
planification rien n'est dans la
préparation c'est pour faire oublier le
fiasco des masques le fiasco des tests
le ch est ce qu bien sûr des vaccins
puisqu'il n'y en a pas assez et puis
cette mesure liberticide à
incompréhensible du couvre-feu à 18h le
la france est le seul pays au monde à
avoir ce couvre-feu à 18 heures sans
parler bien sûr des confinement alors
maintenant ils sont régionaliser locaux
mais qu'est ce qu'elle qu'elle est ce
sens finalement du confinement
le week-end est ce que le virus est plus
virulent le week-end est ce qu'il est
plus dangereux le week-end non bien sûr
il s'agit simplement de dire aux gens
travailler pour le reste on s'en charge
vous restez chez vous et puis si jamais
vous tombez dans la misère on verra pour
les minima sociaux plus tard à quoi
qu'il en coûte ça aura une fin donc on
est vraiment dans un grand n'importe
quoi ou les les français ne comprennent
plus rien et c'est ce qui se passe la
séquence de communication jusqu'à
présent c'était conseil de défense le
mercredi matin à 9h conseil des
ministres dans la foulée déclarations du
porte-parole gabriela talent qui demain
fera sont une vidéo youtube
et puis son nom avait le premier
ministre castex qui faisait une
déclaration le mercredi soir emmanuel
macron qui apparaissait une semaine sur
trois pour dire bon on a fait un truc on
va essayer autre chose ça ne peut pas
durer
les mots maintenant les éléments de
langage utilisé par la majorité
c'est pragmatisme ses stratégies ses
réalisme alors est-ce que ça va être la
suite rassure isme j'en sais rien mais
franchement on se pose des questions sur
sa stratégie alors alexis vous vous
dites tout et communication dans le même
temps il y à quelques élections à venir
dont une de taille inde en maintenant un
peu plus d'un an et ce cas une stratégie
électorale justement sur fond de
contexte de stratégies de crise
sanitaire
oui clairement alors avant l'élection
majeure c'est dans un an
la présidentielle on a les régionales
qui doivent arriver en juin
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs quel mac ont
choisi cette stratégie de
régionalisation de la crise au-delà du
fait de 10 le la responsabilité auprès
des directeurs d était responsable de
région
les directeurs des ars non tout n'est
pas finalement centralisée l'idée c'est
d'aller séduire séduire des élus locaux
des élus qui eux ont le maillage
territorial que la république en marche
n'a pas parce qu'il faut rappeler que le
parti présidentiel a fait un score
calamiteux aux dernières municipales 2
2% sait rien et l'ancrage territorial de
ce parti la république en marche
n'existe pas donc il ne faut pas rater
pour emmanuel macron pour avoir une
chance éventuel en 2022 la marche des
régionales alors il choisit et il s'agit
pour lui d'aller voir un peu plus loin
d'aller aussi draguer sur les terres de
la droite ou d'extrême droite
d'où ces débats qu'on a vu arriver de
nulle part sur le séparatisme sur
l'islamo gauchisme maintenant sur le
lait les cantines scolaires
histoire d'aller voir où se situe
finalement la république en marche
partie opportuniste s'il en est est
maintenant une stratégie claire aller
chercher des élus sur le terrain qu'ils
seront prêts soit faire des coalitions
soit à prendre les tic est en marche
pour ces régionales
ça paraît compliqué rarement des
électeurs changeons nancy peu de deux
semaines de casaque surtout les
électeurs de marine le pen qui vont
toujours préférer l'original à la copie
donc difficile à voir difficile aussi de
voir quelle sera la sanction dans les
urnes finalement en juin pour les
régionales mais clairement cette
stratégie de gestion de crise elle est
dictée par le politique et pas par le
sanitaire d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'avait
dit le secrétaire général des nations
unies en montrant du doigt les pays qui
ont profité de cette crise sanitaire
pour mettre en place des mesures
liberticides et comment ne pas penser à
la france avec ce couvre-feu à 18 heures
avec ces autos attestation de sortie cet
inédit
et puis la loi bien sûr sécurité globale
qui est une loi de surveillance globale
pour faire avancer l'agenda sécuritaire
de surveillance numérique
donc on est là vraiment dans un moment
crucial difficile délicat pour la
république en marche et pourrir et le
maquereau qui voit bien que même s'il
reste à 41 % à peu près d'opinions
favorables
il n'a pas trop perdu depuis le début de
la crise sans néanmoins sa base un peu
faiblir se poser des questions sur sa
capacité de commandes et de gérer
finalement un pays en crise et donc
retour aux fondamentaux de la république
en marche la communication les vidéos
youtube
on verra ce que ça donnera pour les
régionales et puis on verra pour 2022
mais c'est encore plus loin en attendant
les variants sont partout sur le
territoire et les vaccins peine encore à
arriver à ceux qui souhaitent se faire
vacciner
ouais merci alexis poulain
éditorialistes en direct sur rt france